been trying to figure out where do we
gonna place Ichiro when it comes to you
know major league baseball would are we
gonna rank him what are we gonna think
of him in 10 years and what he did for
the sport and the guy who I can ask that
question to joins us now
columnist for mlb.com Richard justice
and Richard how are we gonna speak of
Ichiro in the next 10 years and we think
about what he did for major league
baseball we're gonna speak of him with
reverence you know I'd like to go back
to 2001 at the end of that spring
training I'll bet you there was not one
scout in Major League Baseball did watch
the Mets spring and probably a lot of
coaches and players and managers who
thought he was going to make it he
didn't look like a physically imposing
player he's not a physically imposing
player he had his own way of training he
did more stretching aerobics all that
kind of thing and he just looked over
matched in spring training what he did
in the 2001 season at age 27
Rookie of the Year MVP but beyond that
it's the way he did it he made plays in
right field that would remind you of
Roberto Clemente and that and he was off
and running I mean at 2 batting titles
you know 6 I think 300 hit seasons 10
time all-star one of the great players
that has ever played and you know 4367
hits in Japan in the u.s. he is going
into the Hall of I don't know how we're
gonna remember him in 10 years but in
six years we're gonna put him in the
Hall of Fame on the first ballot no
Richard can we describe anyone else to
his playing style he's just kind of one
of a kind yeah he's one of a kind you
know we're just watching him play the
player I equate him to a little bit is
Wade Boggs
but Ichiro is an outfielder and he just
made plays he had an arm that was one of
the great outfield arms you will ever
see and the thing that people don't know
he speaks his English is fluent but he's
done very few interviews in English
because he's like a lot of foreign-born
players he's not completely comfortable
with the context of his word
I had a friend that asked him in Seattle
hey look I'm leaving town could you just
do one interview with me in English
before I go I may never see you again
and Ichiro says no and he walks away and
he comes back and goes let me rephrase
that he'll know and but before all-star
games is 10 all-star games what became
legendary were his pep talks he is funny
profane pep talks to the American League
squad before all-star games and I guess
if you know and people that players that
were in the room I mean it's a moment
that they never forgot they said the guy
is a funny
he's likable and smart as hell he is you
know if you saw Kikuchi hug him and weep
this morning that tells you what his
peers thought of him do you think that
going forward every pretty much Asian
born player coming from Asia basically
will be linked to Ichiro in terms of
where does what are they compared to
what Ichiro was able to do you know you
know for a while here we complain every
compared every player here that Willie
Mays or Frank Robinson and now you're
gonna compare players to Trout I don't
know that that's fair I just think this
guy is such a freakishly talented player
and such a unique personality we may not
see another one like him again and I say
that knowing that show heyo Tommy has to
be has a chance to be one of the most
interesting players we've ever had but
you know he's just getting started in
the game so we really don't know when
Ichiro we know we know the new 2025 he's
going to all of it well we know at the
age of 27 that rookie season the you
know brookie of the year the MVP those
kind of numbers and he did it for know
so long but if you think about what he
was able to accomplish five years into
his major league baseball career and you
think about if he did it right now and
you look at the contracts that were
given out to Machado Harper now trout
what do you think that contract would
look like for Ichiro had he been playing
right now and if I Mookie
who's kind of on a similar path today
after winning an MVP what does that
contract look like right now after
seeing what Mike Trout got okay well
he's made it he made 167 million in his
career so he did okay for himself I
think well we're in a launch angle era
now right and I think we saw enough to
know that if Ichiro had wanted to hit
home runs and that's what makes you a
lot of money now he could have hit home
run I think he would have gotten you
know what's the gold standard now is 30
plus million dollars a year he would
have been in that because I mean the guy
had a the guy was on base all the time
yes he had a better than yet a better
than 380 on-base percentage you know for
about half his years he he he got he
made 200 hips look easy
he made 262 hits 1 year look easy so I
don't know what he would have gotten
because you have to factor in the fact
that strikeouts and home runs or what
people are paying the best dollars for
but you know is he comparable to Mookie
Betts no but he's a great player
columnist for mlb.com Richard Justus
joining the Rich Eisen shell Kirk
Morrison filling in for rich but kind of
sticking on mookie betts though right
now he's had a one-year twenty million
dollar contract says he's not concerned
about the long term deal but at what
point do the Boston Red Sox say you know
what we got a we got to figure this
thing out because if he reached his free
agency he's gonna break the bank so how
do you think the Boston Red Sox and
Mookie Betts kind of move about goodness
long-term contract probably settled well
they've made him a couple offers I think
in the area of 200 million and hasn't
gotten it done so he threw the Boston
Red Sox while you do have him for two
more years and he is 26 years old you
want to get this done now the backdrop
of that is over the next two years Chris
Sale Rick Porcello Xander Bogaerts
Jackie Bradley jr. also creates and the
Red Sox have said we can't keep them all
but this is your number one guy you have
to keep him you know and given where he
plays the way he plays and just the way
he looks you know his facial expressions
is purr
personality all of that if if you want
to make the case that he's the face of
baseball that would be a pretty easy
case to make
so look he understands this what he said
yesterday to reporters probably wouldn't
give the Red Sox a lot of comfort he
said I want to be treated fairly and so
what is fairly mean you know does that
mean Harper or trout or Machado or
something in that area he's the only
player I think you could mention in the
same breath as trout right now so that
that's what we're looking at Mike just
signed a ten-year 360 million dollar
extension that's the that's the
parameter let's go from there you know
Richard one of the things I'm looking at
now where's you look at the big contract
signed this offseason I mentioned with
Harper Machado obviously with trout is
this something to be said now that teams
are looking at the price that they're
going to have to pay in future years
that you look at a team like the Chicago
White Sox who signed Eloy him in as
their top prospect you know they got in
the Cubs deal from with Jose Quintana
they signed him to the richest contract
that's six years 43 million dollars for
a guy who hasn't even played in the
major leagues yet are we going to see
more team start to give money more
upfront so that they don't have to so
they can wait a little bit longer in the
backend to get those big deals I think
what's changed is the players are more
open to those deals in that it was
always you know like when Alex Bregman
was signed a five-year hundred million
dollar extension this week yes when he
got renewed he was ticked about it and I
had veteran players tell me I always got
renewed but you got renewed knowing that
you you're gonna get the hammer and it's
going to be if you're a good player it's
going to be a big one the pre agent
market has changed for age 31 and older
players it's almost gone away in a lot
of cases so you so you are open to those
deals in a way you would have been open
to them before when the Rays game Evan
Longoria his first contract they told
him up front look if you're the player
we think you are this may not be a great
deal for you but this does provide you
with financial security
and in sort of a certainty about what we
think of you and when he outplayed the
contract they tore it up when Sal Perez
outplayed his contract in Kansas City
they tore it up and I would assume in
the case of Eloy and Bregman if they out
play those contracts they look at them
again but yeah the free agent and
there's conversations going on between
the owners and players now players
always got paid biggest money in the
second half of the career players peak
performance here is age twenty seven on
average they've got to get more of that
money up front because the team's now
driven by data and information are just
not going to go age 32 33 34 seasons
with insane money unless that player is
really special rich our Justice
columnist for mlb.com during the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison here filling in
for rich and the thing about it richer
though is with my NFL background NFL
players will hold out if they don't like
the contract that they're in and a guy
like Eloy jimenez could he be a guy or
others saying hey I feel like I'm
outplayed this contract I'm worth way
more money than what I originally saw
could we possibly see holdouts maybe
four guys in the future no I think the
dynamic in baseball is different you get
a deal done and you know in the case of
Eloy now you know Alex Bregman might be
a better example running because he has
a track record
Eloy has zero days in the big leagues
and what this contract does is assure
they don't to play that you know that
game of leaving him down for two service
time manipulation I'm leaving him down
for two weeks to get an extra year of
control they've got him signed for the
next six years
who's theirs yeah I think those are
delicate things like if you overplay the
contract what do you do about that
I mean coca-cola it's been very
underpaid for the last few years and
he's just kept his mouth shut and played
and knowing I will be afraid in it you
know when I'm on one year from now and
I'll get it back then it's delicate
holding out just doesn't seem to work in
the in the in the in the baseball world
right now you know Richard I'm all
about who's next up and you mentioned
mookie betts they've already offered him
a deal the Red Sox did and just they're
kind of figuring out that but what about
the Yankees and an erring judge who's
still in his rookie deal have they've
been talking an extension and what does
that number possibly look like yeah I
don't think they're there yet I think
they would be willing to do that but I
think the Yankees are a little bit
different dynamic in that the Yankees
have no insecurities about loosing a guy
because the money now would they like to
sew him up and have some cost certainty
about it and let's say it's on a side
note he is having an unbelievably
great-looking spring even by his own
standards so yeah I I don't think I
think that's on the horizon but you know
he is not he's not going to be a free
agent until 2023 so there's no urgency
to it he's arbitration eligible after
this season and we'll see where that
goes it would be logical to do that
after this after this season but don't
believe those things have gotten serious
you haven't said that having said that
there he'll probably announcer the
announcer deal in an hour from now you
can reach them on Twitter at Richard
Justice columnist for mlb.com right here
Richard justice joined the Rich Eisen
show and you said the the age 31 and
older that was usually for position
players right because I look at free
agency right now and you've got pitchers
like Dallas Keuchel and cake Crimbo okay
Craig Kimbrel who are still unsigned and
I'm trying to figure out why is that is
the numbers just too high or are they
just gonna hold out and wait out because
you got guys who are 30 and 31
respectively yeah Craig wanted a
six-year contract that just never been
done for a relief pitcher maybe misread
the market you know Louie and I mean
he's going to end up somewhere so the
question becomes should he wait until
after the you know eye injuries are
going to come up in the case of Dallas
when he won the site young in 2015 the
Astros offered him I think it was five
years ninety million dollars more
recently I think he kind of used Patrick
Corbin's contract six years as a gauge
and it just for whatever
reason the market hasn't been there the
Astros I think seeing the team beat the
team he's most likely to sign with but
that's been a one-year or a two-year
deal we live in a high spin rate high
velocity game right now for pitchers in
baseball that's not Keiko
but he's very effective I just think
that he you know he wanted more than the
market would bear and that's one of the
things Commissioner Manfred has said is
you know if it's a free market economy
you have to understand that it cuts both
ways so I hope he's selling soon the
game the game is not well served by guys
like that not being in uniform but the
market is the market and and free agency
can be a slap in the face for guys while
it also rewards many guys hey Richard
one more before I let you go we you know
obviously the earth
Bryce Harper deal has been signed it's
done but what does that put four
expectations for the Philadelphia
Phillies going into this season if they
don't make the playoffs oh are we
getting hon Bryce Harper what's the
expectations now that he signed that
deal for the Phillies you know I'm
reminded of when Jason Giambi signed
with the Yankees and he was getting
booed in his first month in New York and
Derek Jeter put an arm around him one
day and said hey buddy they really want
to cheer you but this is New York and
you got to give them a reason they're
not going to just tear you because
you're here so you know it's Philly you
got to win you got to perform what are
the expectations for that kind of
contract the expectations are you in or
ulcers are you play in a World Series or
you have an MVP type season all of those
things is he capable to doing that this
is a really really good baseball team
but the Washington Nationals are really
good the Braves and the Mets are really
good they're not guaranteed of anything
I hope he gets off to a good start and
quiets all those noisy fans in
Philadelphia because they will boo it's
not like other places they're not going
to love you just because you we're in
our uniform well we shall see they
always a pleasure appreciate the time
Richard Thank You Kurt that's Richard
Justice columnist for mlb.com the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience